(playful music)
Hi, I'm Sequoia Holmes.
I just took an Ancestry DNA Kit Test,
and my results were super surprising.
So today I'm going to be making a dish
that dates back to my earliest ancestors.
Today, I'm going to ease myself into it,
make something really simple.
I'm going to make amiwo with
mojo sauce and grilled chicken.
When I first got my Ancestry DNA results,
I was really surprised how
specific the results were.
I was really shocked
to see Benin on there.
I knew nothing about Benin.
So, I was really excited
and immediately started
researching everything
that I could find about it.
I found out it was the
birthplace of voodoo.
Thought that was really cool.
Also found out that they
have a really vibrant
food scene.
I'm a very beginner
cook, so I wanted to go
easy on myself and choose something that
wasn't going to be super difficult.
I chose amiwo, which you
probably have never heard of.
It's a really simple,
authentic, savory cake.
I would compare it to polenta.
You can serve this with fried
chicken, grilled chicken,
sometimes fish. But I
chose grilled chicken
today because it's easy.
I grew up eating a lot of barbecue.
My mom owned a few barbecue restaurants.
I feel like, the way that I know it,
and soul food, the way that I know it,
are both American cuisines.
All I could connect to was America
and American cuisines, specifically.
So, it was really important
for me to get a deeper
sense of self.
Now we are going to make a mojo sauce.
Mojo sauce has red
peppers, habanero pepper.
And it has the coolest name ever!
Mojo sauce...yes!
I like a little bit of a kick,
a little bit of a spice in my food.
When you add a habanero, it gives it
just a tiny bit of a
kick, but nothing major.
If you don't like any spice at all,
feel free to leave out
the habanero entirely.
Now that I have my DNA results,
I'm really happy to
share it with my family.
Share this meal with my family.
See what they think of it.
I think they're going to love it.
My mom would be so proud of me for
making this on my own.
I encourage everyone out
there to do the same.
This has been such a
cool experience for me.
Now that I've made this dish,
I can move on to the
rest of my DNA results.
I have so much more to
explore, and I can't wait.
(playful music)
Oh my god! This is so good.